i'm joined now by the man himself don
cheadle aka
war machine uh don thanks for being here
glad to be here manny congrats on the
show
on election night thank you so much on
election night you were on the daily
show literally plugging your ears
because you didn't want to know how the
results were going where were you when
you heard
five days later that biden had won and
what did you do in those
intervening five days did you try and
stay away from the news all week till
saturday morning
i did i did i i you know it was it was
strange i was really
sort of holding my breath the entire
time i didn't realize
how stressed out i was until afterwards
um
i'm in detroit i'm still in detroit i'm
working on a movie so i was right
about here when uh i found out
what had happened and you know the next
day i i
went on to the set and you know although
there
was a uh a result i guess we're still
waiting to
confirm a result through all of these
legal imaginations that are happening
now so
it was very strange for me to be in a
swing state in this swing state in
particular that you know
and to have a very you know we have a
mix of people on set
we don't just we're just not all lefties
on set you know we have
a very mixed we have independents we
have republicans so
it was a very interesting situation uh
and discussions around the election for
sure
it's funny you mentioned you had
republicans on set i was gonna say what
was their reaction because
it's interesting because after joe biden
was called the winner you tweeted
inhale exhale pause take it in
level out resist the urge leave the crow
in the stove
unserved if it feels good don't do it
roll up your sleeves
now it's time to go to work admirable
sentiments not admirable sentiments in
theory
i just want to play to you what whoopi
goldberg said a slightly different take
to you on the view have a listen
now i just i want to bring something up
right now i want to say to all those
people
who don't believe that americans
actually got out and voted
let me say this to you when you know who
was elected four years ago
you know hillary clinton didn't say hey
wait a minute this doesn't feel right
stop the count she didn't say this isn't
right i'm not going for she didn't say
any of that
so all of you suck it up suck it up like
we sucked it up
don you have to admit don't you that at
a time like this after years of
pain and trauma you can't just ask
people to resist the urge as
noble as that sentiment is you have to
be realistic about it
fair to people i'm saying to me it's
resist the urge
to dunk on people in a manner in which
you were not appreciative of being
quote unquote dunked on uh and and i
mean right now
in everything there is a time and in
every place under the sun there's a
moment for things to happen
so i just think that we can get into
uh a sort of a feedback loop that
ultimately
isn't helpful when what we're really
trying to do is figure out a way to move
forward with
the as many people that want to move
forward with us as
as will um there's always going to be
a segment of folks that are never going
to accept that no matter what happens
and those people we just have to write
off yeah but for the majority
i think it's easier to to to make moves
and to
to progress in the way that we're going
to need to if we're not stuck in this
thing of everybody going
in yeah it's just it's just not
productive and i'm like saying
if you want to do that let's do it to
each other we can keep all that stuff
online but let's not just jump on
twitter and facebook and
i can get in every way that we can sort
of get into these silos where we're just
no i appreciate each other and we're not
moving
i appreciate your point about just not
dunking for the sake of dunking but
you know when you hear people saying we
need to heal we need to reach out to
trump voters
surely you understand you know you're a
black man i'm a brown man for a lot of
people in our communities it's not so
easy just to reach out to people who
have literally been voting
for your oppression and subjugation
banning you from entering the country
one hundred percent and the thing is
when you've won
as i believe we legitimately have it's
you don't have to we've already won
that's the biggest dunk that there is
joe biden
is the president kamala harris will be
his vp that's
happening whether you want to deal with
it or not we're in this you know legal
these these these illegal which is just
really clearly
uh out of um a desperate grab and it's
not going to change
um the electors in the the cities are
not the states that we're talking about
aren't they're saying there's no real
argument here these are
there's not real legal precedent for
these things to be happening but we've
got to go through this process that's
fine at the end of it
like we are now we will still have one
okay so i think there's something
between
not dunking and just going whatever and
that's where i think we need to be
i think ultimately what we're gonna want
to do is try to move forward with as
many people as we can
and look the win isn't is just the start
we know as we've said you and i both
know we're very aware we're paying
attention it's your job it's something
i'm very passionate about and paying
attention to
that there is a desire for many people
to just default to what was considered
the norm and go back to a situation
indeed and i don't think that's the
mandate that we have now i think the
progressives have won
their elections and we got to move
forward
so you're on that note on moving forward
i'm not going back to default
you say you've been passionate about
something you've been very passionate
outspoken about is climate change
one of the biggest issues on the agenda
right now if not the biggest you've been
involved with numerous climate change
organizations you've been sounding the
alarm on this for many years now
joe biden has said he's not for the
green new deal but he will be rejoining
the paris climate accords
and he has put together what many think
is a strong plan an ambitious climate
plan
but i wonder is it ambitious enough is
it good enough for you given where we
are now
given the truly existential and urgent
threat posed to all of us by climate
change
um no i don't i don't think it i don't
think it really is
but i do think and i'm hopeful that
the team that will be built around him
and
that the inroads that we have with the
team that will be around him
there will be more of an ability to to
move that conversation forward there
will definitely be more amenable to that
uh than if the other administration had
stayed in power that wants to say it's
not even real
uh so yeah it's it's always going to be
a fight because we know there's going to
be a lot of hard decisions that have to
be made and there's going to be a lot of
of shifting away from what we are used
to and what is the norm
and to lean into more innovative ways to
to
to move forward through this and and to
give up a lot of the stuff that we've
been relying on and that's
never done easily there's always got to
be a push so
we're just in for a long fight and we
know what it is and we hope that we can
outpace the
the realities that are coming at us day
to day we just got to fight
so don are you for the green new deal
yourself or are you someone that thinks
it's got a lot of good policies in it
but strategically the name
the messaging turned some people off as
a few house democrats have argued in
recent days
well i think those are people who are
like like i said that are afraid of the
messaging
and that are afraid of what it actually
means to
to take those steps and haven't really
quantified ways
to uh you know what do green
jobs look like versus the jobs that
we've been used to
and will we be able to really build a a
robust economy
leaning into green jobs as we have been
doing what we've done which is taking us
down the bad road with oil and gas
and i believe that we can but again
nothing
succeeds on its own so it's going to be
a
a constant push and people yeah we want
to get trapped into names and
and what it says and our reactions it's
emotional reactions we have to
what things are phrased and what the
phraseology is around them rather than
actually looking into them substantively
and saying
what does this mean so again it's going
to be
constantly like two steps forward and
one step back but
this is this is the process we just have
to keep pushing
indeed well said you've also been
outspoken about voter suppression we saw
what happened in georgia in 2018 in
stacy abraham's gubernatorial run and
now two years later
uh we've seen how turnout could very
well push biden
to victory in the very same state how do
people keep that momentum
going to ensure that voting is made
easier
for all americans and especially brown
and black voters in so-called
red states but which are really voter
suppression states
yeah we we need to figure out a way to
clone stacy
and and and move her out to all of these
states and and really
look at what she has done and try to
replicate that because you know i think
what we've seen more than anything is
that sweat equity
wins the day you have to be out there
you have to be on the front lines we
have to support people
who are who are doing that work day to
day and that's what i can do with my
platform that's what you can do with
your platform
that's what you know those of us who are
in the public eye have an ability to do
is to
take that attention and to place it
where it should be
and and support people who really
understand the mechanisms and
and how that works and just keep ringing
that bell that
that our vote is important that our vote
does matter you know a lot of that was
combated very clearly in this election
it's very hard to me to believe that
people could still look at this election
and go well my vote doesn't matter it's
like
your vote clearly matters it's always
mattered or they wouldn't be trying to
keep it
from you so so let's let's do everything
that we can to support people like
stacey and support people who understand
who are on the ground that are
pushing this forward and that's the best
thing that we can do
yeah and in terms of keeping ringing the
bell this year we also saw the nation
begin to reckon with racial injustice as
a whole and especially
police brutality months-long protests
after the death of george floyd and
brianna taylor and many others
sadly you've actually said the protests
might be the one good thing to come out
of the trump presidency
but the thing is police brutality
pre-dates trump and it won't just
disappear when biden comes in
so how does the nation keep up the
protests and the energy and the activism
on this
that we saw over the summer once biden
is sworn in are you worried because i'm
worried that people say ah joe biden's
and donald trump's gone
i can get back to my stuff i don't need
to worry about things like you know
racism or police violence anymore
yeah that's what i'm saying i think
there is a very human
need you know and i put it in the tweet
that you put up we have to exhale
we have to take a minute to let your
nervous system
you know recalibrate and get back to a
place where you can
you know get ready to re-engage because
you're absolutely right this isn't going
to go away just because we have a new
administration it predates him it
predates them
and it's something that we understand
the prevalence of because now there are
more cell phone cameras but this is
something
that's been happening you know ad
nauseum since this whole country began
it's a
unbroken line in many ways from from
from slavery
uh from you know uh something that we've
seen we're talking about the prison
system the the penal system how we
how we have to deal with that as well so
again
i think if there is a good thing in my
opinion that came out of this it woke
everybody up
and it uh allowed people to realize that
their voice is important
and when they show up people have to
respond
the leaders have to leadership has to
respond and
we have the ability to change policy but
not
if we go good that's over now we can
relax we can't relax there is no
relaxing
unfortunately you just got to keep
paddling that boat
upstream and and get to the next result
and and as you said so well just that
you know it woke people up and yet
that phrase woke is now used as a
pejorative it's somehow bad to be aware
of
racial or structural injustice it's
something to be mocked let me ask you
this before we run out of time
you are of course best known these days
including in my house
as an avenger as war machine what did
you make of the spoof video that we
played a moment ago that a fan made
with all of the end game characters as
different political figures after the
election
and your character was rbg
i was i was very happy about that i
don't know why they had to stick sean
connery on my shoulder
um they could have picked somebody else
i don't understand that
i was like are you that of this i don't
know what that was elon musk
why was elon musk at it why is elon in
there why is hunter in there drunk with
a cigarette hanging out in his mouth i
mean
i i think there was a bit of it you know
we had to serve he had to serve a little
bit up for other people i get that
whatever that's fine
but look this it it was amazing are you
going to be
rbg great yeah i loved being rbg and
what's great is that you know
it was both symbolic and and humorous
you know
and and very authentically true as well
and i think you know one of the things
that you see in that thing is like
everybody
showing up and this was the culmination
to me
of all of the energy of that you know
everything that happened from
you know from february to now has really
been this
upheaval and this this you know this
this recurrence of people understanding
how they are a part of this process you
know you get in where you fit in
and people have been looking for ways to
fit in and where they get in
and i think it's robust and there
absolutely
uh is a desire to go huh
and exhale and step back but that can
only be a reset that's a moment to like
re recalibrate get your soul together
the human
nervous system only takes so much and
this has been an incredibly stressful
amount of time that we've gone through
so self-care take care of yourself do
what you need to do
out gas and then let's get back on it
don we're out of time but i'm gonna ask
you this anyways very briefly i have to
ask as an avengers fan
i loved endgame i loved you in endgame
and you had some of the best lines on
time travel in that movie
but did you really understand the mcu
version of time travel because i wanted
to
but i didn't well i think if you can
really understand
time travel then we're both probably in
the wrong business i think the best that
we could do
is uh come up with something that is
entertaining and makes the audience go
like
all right
yeah well you did that don cheadle thank
you so much for your time and for
joining me today we appreciate it
thank you matty you're doing a great
thing out there i don't know why anybody
uh would really submit to an interview
with you who can't stand up some
questions
because you're the bomb everybody should
do it like you do it that's real tough